tu es un gros faux
pourquoi tu es incroyablement irresponsable tu
n'écoutes pas tu es fou tu es égoïste
tu n'es pas la seule personne Charl je
pensais que c'était différent avec elle mais
alors stand je ne veux pas être avec toi
quoi
que ce soit rembobiner qu'avez-vous fait elle a dit qu'elle
ne voulait pas être dans le dessin toutes les
autres filles bien évidemment je suis totalement d'
accord avec le fait qu'une image clignote dans
mon esprit me fait l'aimer à nouveau
avec Halloween elle était une dame indienne
êtes-vous  un homme
bien sûr je suis Shelley tout le monde je ne peux pas
nous parler franchement du cœur qui
était assez proche
c'est ennuyeux l'oublier
je ne pense pas avoir la capacité de
retomber amoureux nous avons entendu parler de la
bataille des sexes  mec c'est ça
oh c'est Charlie tu es dingue je sais que je le suis